最後に家をはじめ社長です今日はこちらモーリーファンタジー3に入っているんです
けどもう
スゲー人に見られますね森本持参でぬいぐるみだしたことあるんですけども今回はそれ
のでかいバージョンが新しく出ますっ
見てみましょうかこちらですが昔あったのはー
ところぞてょだったんですけどもう今回はノー新しい
ピンクの
みんな京都がらせとか山岸低いこれよりマネージャーさんが知ってる
今回はこちら弾み殺王と山岸めぐみちゃんの2種類展開でございますこんでくれただ
とるんじゃなくてちょっと検証してみたいことが一つありまして
ufoキャッチャーって100円入れて1回できるじゃないですか
100円だろうあまりに入れすぎると
4回200円た版入んなくなっちゃって止まっちゃう時があるんですよエラーってそれ
やってみてなっ
思った分けるこういうことを意図的にやるとちょっとなんかを見てみがかかるんで
ちょっと許可をとってちゃんとやっておりますなんで僕はも今合法的に両方
キャッチャーはエラーにできる権利を得ていますあれどれ
今ちょっとどれぐらい溜まってるかわからない状態なのでまああくまで参考例の一つと
して見ていただけると助かります
切れ痔初期投資2万円分ですちなみにこの台は
1ズレ200円なんで100円だが200万円で100回できますだけでまずは100
回やってみましょう
txt スパ可能出ればもう全部取りたいくらいの勢いだという
あああああ
えっ
別マッハん
car
3階できますはい
もちろんえん
集めたん
たシフォンに作りましたシューテ入りますせめて
療法は持つ帰りたいたのよええ
ああああああ
ボールと移ったボーリング釣れましたあるのです
そんなメイソンホラー
どうぞ
本当にてご挨拶
ああああああ
goo
rar
キー4倍ズーム smiler でます
ear
おっありがとうですか待った後語る
ああああああ
あこれめっちゃ by 濡れません
どんどんやりましょうもん
あっはーるよ車
あえてあげるうち1個いとれました続いて恵ちゃんとっていきます
こんな感じでって書いてあるのが特徴的ですインターネットポックラブ
乾者の欲しかったあの1回でコツは覚えたんで明日はもう徐々に
[音楽]
一発きたんじゃないこれ
まあまあせて異様な事態です
きた身だしなみたをん
[音楽]
me
ana
これウマニスかネタバトルの上です
はぁ
バーンズええええ
わあああああんんん
はいいんじゃないかなぁ
可愛いねこれを誓いとないです
思い
すごい
うまいこれは大幹部投げまでに完全に食い込んでいる
シャーシャーに超えるゲッター
これでいいか揃えました申し上げますめぐみちゃんに進む
car
英知が1感じが近くなった今90万入ってます
清
それで10枚入れると今
100円玉100前僕一人で行けたことになりますはい言い訳
100円玉100万入れましたまだまだ線90009問い続けます
うざいこの子が線級と言わなくなるまでておりません
はいというわけで100円玉を痛くない使うでもまだ
1900れますあと100円の100枚あるのでどんどん入れていこうと思います
102件103
tl 104
i am
wh
16できっ
設計なざき
人たち
by 選挙じゃなかったこれ
つまりましたここまでっていうことですねはいというわけだ
つまりましたでまぁとサントリーの思ってるんでこの3点で御恵ちゃんを撮れますその
後3回
いますと2回それその1
これ
ベビーちゃ
me
はいというわけで検証結果この台はひゃっふーこないけどを入れると止まってしまい
ました
105枚やってる間に撮れたのがこちらの
肇社長と恵ちゃんとからボールロボでした
ありがとうございますはいでこの肇社長とめぐみちゃんの巨大でイーグル3なんです
けどもう4月の20 c 力で
僕のモーリーファンタジー3で順次展開予定でございますめちゃくちゃて解釈僕はして
いるせ可愛いのでみなさんぜひ撮ってみてください
早生なんと色違いの味目社長のぬいぐるみをありますこの色違いのはじめ車窓のぬい
ぐる b
ネットで出来るオンラインクレーンゲームモーリー恩来っていうのがあるんですけども
それ限定で手に入れることができます
おうちでもどこでもできるので皆さんぜひこの色違いと肇社長のチェックしてみて
くださいばいばーい
[音楽]
me
バッハ
気がします
conoha
re 11 a
一ポイントでした